the bullet holes in destruction are
testament to the ferocity of a tribal
battle the city of Zawiya in western
libya saw heavy fighting
following the revolution overthrew
Libya's longtime ruler Rama Gaddafi nine
years ago the fighting was between Pro
and anti Gadhafi tribes since then into
tribal dialogue has broad agreement and
relative calm muñeca brothers they sat
down and made concessions on issues that
may have fueled that conflict that's the
main reason why we survived but tribal
loyalties are being tested again as the
Civil War shows no sign of ending some
areas close to Zambia are heavily
populated by tribes loyal to Khalifa
Haftar the warlord launched a military
campaign to seize power from the UN bank
government in Tripoli in April his
forces control around 70% of the country
is often heavy fighting in the sub
neighborhoods of the capital afters
forces shall the only operational
international air brought in Tripoli
virtually every day to the west ins Orr
a port town inhabited by mainly Berber
tribes on the Tunisia border leaders say
after is trying to galvanize support
among Arab tribes and his fighters have
been seen trying to surround the area
the eminent Madhya in the last couple of
days we have noticed suspicious
activities a military reinforcements on
the outskirts after surveillance in the
city there has been a general
mobilization of security forces and
resources have been allocated to counter
an offensive in January Pro half the
tribes forced the closure of Libya's
main all infrastructure in eastern Libya
depriving the un-backed governments of
billions of dollars in revenue tribal
loyalties are now being tested to the
west of Tripoli as huffed US forces
trying to open a new front in the chaos
that this country has suffered since the
revolution that overthrew marma Gaddafi
in 2011 reconciliation between certain
tribes was only possible because of the
great effort of tribal leaders and civil
society groups the repeated failure of
UN sponsored cease
tox means fears are growing among many
Libyans that tribal divisions are being
exploited again Charles trafford al
Jazeera Tripoli